la Guadeloupe ce sera telle la naissance
de nouveau gilet jaune pour Emmanuel
Macron c'est à voir on sait que le
stress indiqué que la colère gronde
souvent et que donc ça peut rester
circonscrit là-bas néanmoins je pense
que c'est vraiment un moment d'alerte et
Emmanuel Macron au gouvernement de
ressentir passer le vent du boulet et ça
sans déconner sur cette cette révolte
qui vont là-bas mais bien sûr parce que
cette révolte elle peut s'étendre
au-delà de la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique et allez bien sûr toucher la
métropole en disant tout simplement 2
ans de gestion sanitaire sur autoritaire
liberticide ce que dit ce monsieur sur
le fait d'être esclave quand on perd sa
liberté ça peut commencer à imprimer en
disant mais attendez c'est pas un vaccin
qui va me rendre ma liberté c'est pas un
pas sanitaire sur mon status sérologique
qui doit me donner des droits que
d'autre part on est là complètement dans
une rupture du parti républicain
liberté-égalité-fraternité
extrêmement grave